summerlin is expanding with new housing
and developments major construction is
underway right now near the las vegas
ballpark and it's set to be complete by
the end of the year madison kimbrough
joins us live tonight with reaction from
those living in summerlin madison
howard hughes corporation has signed two
new leases as you can see and it's right
by the las vegas ballpark that's all
mentioned in detail according to
summerlin.com described as a 10 story
class a office building under
development at 1700 pavilion clark hill
international law firm will occupy more
than 13 thousand square feet of it while
er injury attorneys will occupy
approximately 7 300 square feet the
project is set to be finished by the end
of this year and as of now it's 39
percent leased out in addition there's
also new apartment housing going up near
the office building as of now we don't
believe the two are connected some
people in the area pleased with the new
developments while others say they were
hoping for more parking
parking lots here are always packed no
matter what i was praying it was going
to be a parking garage so no one didn't
have to come over here now but there are
still going to be a ton of people that
are going to do that because people
don't want to get food here go shopping
after
and luckily there will be more parking
in addition to these office buildings
but it's unknown if the parking garage
will only be for those that work at 1700
pavillion or open to shoppers and
baseball game attendees now 1700
pavilion will include touchless entry
points and a shared common area within
the first floor of the lobby reporting
live in downtown summerlin madison kim
bro live local now